la mayoría vienen de la golpeada y ti y
otros de cuba venezuela y nicaragua unos
10.500 migrantes se reunieron bajo el
puente internacional del río en la noche
del jueves protegiéndose de las olas de
calor que alcanzan temperaturas de
alrededor de los 37 grados celsius las
condiciones de lo que ahora es un
campamento improvisado son miserables y
los suministros de comida de agua se
están agotando la patrulla fronteriza
anunció que incrementará su personal en
del río texas en respuesta a la nueva
emergencia fronteriza que enfrenta a la
administración de bite en la patrulla
fronteriza está incrementando sus tropas
en el sector de del río y coordinando
esfuerzos con el departamento de
seguridad nacional y otras oficinas
federales estatales y locales para
abordar el nivel de migrantes y para
facilitar un proceso seguro humano y
ordenado
la aglomeración sea cuando el cruce
ilegal alcanza las cifras más altas en
20 años y el tiempo en que el gobierno
de eeuu que está batallando por el
reasentamiento de migrantes afganos se
cree que los migrantes que han llegado
al de río hacen parte de una oleada de
haitianos que van hacia eeuu muchos de
los cuales llegaron a sudamérica tras el
terremoto de 2010 según las más
recientes cifras de la patrulla
fronteriza por lo menos 29 mil haitianos
han llegado a eeuu en los últimos 11
meses los más recientes tras el
asesinato del presidente haitiano joven
el movice y el devastador terremoto de
agosto según comunicó un funcionario de
la administración de biden a apple el
gobierno planea una expulsión a gran
escala de migrantes haitianos desde una
ciudad fronteriza de texas a la isla a
partir del domingo contradiciendo al
comunicado previo además las autoridades
de eeuu cerraron el tráfico vehicular y
peatonal por el cruce fronterizo por
razones de seguridad y protección